all right think I can start okay um
welcome back everybody to the second
session and our second speaker of today
which would be soong Lee and she will
talk about endogenous Market formation
Theory and evidence from Chan College
admission thank you
um uh first first of all it's a great
honor to be here and meeting old friends
I think I would have more friends
familiar but mostly new and for those
who don't know me my name is Le and as I
can see a puzzling and confusing and
very difficult to follow a face is that
my first name is too complicated for non
Korean so don't worry about it just go
me show all right and this paper is
joint work with my friends uh Ricardo
Espinosa at and Hector Lopez
Anda and um and I'm from an a background
of applied Economist so I'm mostly more
familiar with the data analysis and so
maybe the perspective or the main focus
could be a little bit different from a
computer scientist for sure and a
theorist but bear with me that why I
think it's still interesting to you and
if I'm successful for next 30 minutes
then you will agree with me otherwise
you can tell me afterward all
right okay so for this group I don't
have to say how great this Market design
is and um but still for the wrapping up
why I'm interested in this particular
project is that one of the area Market
designers are very successful in real
world and theoretical perspective is in
the application of student and school
matching and in fact there are a couple
of cases and more than growing number of
cases in the real world that adoption of
well-designed centralized matching
algorithm or Market design algorithm has
been applied and actually shows some
evidence that there could be a very
significant uh Improvement due to using
this well-designed matching algorithm um
but then obviously despite this huge uh
potential benefits and actually realized
benefit there are not to my point of
view as many applications could be used
in the real world and they may me wonder
why this is the case and my
interpretation is that not all Market
participants are fine with we're happy
with the Improvement of efficiency and
actually some of them are better off
under more malfunctioning situation
and because of this nature of conflict
they're usually third party intervention
namely policy intervention is usually
needed and but then I found out a very
interesting case from Chile from my
friend Ricardo who is from Chile that
for chile and College admission actually
some of them and growing number of them
are using centralized matching which is
very unusual without the intervention of
third party namely government and the
first case happened in
1967 that some colleges basically at the
time is all fouryear colleges at the
time is a number of eight voluntarily
formed the centralized matching system
to give one only one admission to the
applicant pool uh and that's been
happening until
2011 um but in the meantime what
happened between the uh 70 in the
between of 7 67 and 2012 there were
around uh there a batch of new colleges
established especially in the 1980s and
their share of this new colleges have
been growing but there would not be a
part of the centralized matching but
they are more like a secondary or
marginalized system but then what
happened in 2012 is that this origional
members of the centralized matching
system decided to invite this new
College to join them and actually that
happened in 2012 and some of this new
College joined the system and the
coverage of the matching system
initially was 100% for foure colleges
and it dropped to 50% in 2011 and then
because of the change 20% to point
increase
in terms of the coverage of centralized
maging so that made me wonder why this
is happening at the initial period why
this uh this fouryear colleges in Chile
uh show this unique uh decision to form
a centralized maging which happen been
shown in many other countries as far as
I know and that why is the case that
they decide to open up this coverage of
centralized matching for the new
colleges and why they didn't do it in
before but now in 2012 they decide to do
it so my questions why this is happening
and then what is the consequences of the
uh change in terms of the adoption of
the centralized meing and expansion of
centralized matching in terms of
students at school so those are the two
questions and I address these two
questions both Theory and empirics but
mostly the fun uh focus is an empirical
part so today I'll briefly touch upon
the key features of the Chilean College
admission system and I will show you a
very simple two-sided matching model the
theory itself doesn't have much of a
merit but still still to me is useful
because it guide me what kind of
Statistics what kind of empirical
analysis I could do using the
administrative data for the two-sided
matching model there are only two
colleges that capture a group of
colleges in Chile and students are
assumed to be heterogeneous in terms of
their preferences over these two
colleges and test score and importantly
the their ability to apply to two
colleges so we assume that one college
is free of charge in terms of the
application but the other one cost money
for the college application so this is
where uh the quotequote the search uh
cost will kick in and empirical analysis
will uh examine the some features that
model generate and actually that is uh
the case in Chile or not using the data
from 2010 to
2013 so the what is the main uh
assumptions or what is the main
driver versus not that is coming from
the comparability between colleges what
I mean by comparability is from the
students's point of view whether they
like college one versus College two vice
versa that probability if is close to
one half it means that two colleges for
the students point of view they are
indifferent right and then uh in terms
of the affordability of application cost
if the share of students who can apply
for both colleges with enough resources
then there is not much going on in
between the two but if there is a chunk
of students who cannot apply both
colleges because of resource constraint
then maybe there could be some way to
address it by uh uh by reducing the
search cost by forming a centralized
matching and by centralized matching I
assume that the cost of college
application eliminated that's the the
key
feature and then uh because of this uh
uh reduction in application cost using
centralized matching it implies that the
vacancy could be reduced and the flip
side of the vacancy will be the
enrollment could go up uh in terms of
the raw number of the uh in terms of the
raw number of students who enrolled in
each college or the test adjusted a test
score adjusted enrollment in both cases
we show that the Improvement um for the
students point of view the increase in
enrollment or reduction in vacancy what
it means from the student point of view
is their probability to get a a College
admission will go up so for that will be
beneficial to all students on average
but because of this application cost for
students who are were not able to apply
both colleges or all colleges because of
their research constraint um adopting
the centralized matching which reduce
the application cost into zero that will
be particularly beneficial for students
who are not able to apply uh to colleges
or all colleges in this case because of
the family background so this is the uh
uh uh main finding I will I will show
you for simple theory model and also the
empirical analysis so how this paper
fits into the literature and obviously
there are a lot of studies in terms of
student School matching and many of you
are contributed to the literature so I
will not say all of it um but in
addition from my perspective what has
been very uh exciting and encouraging to
me is that from the both Market
designers perspective and also the
empirical applied people's perspective
there are growing number of studies that
try to highlight what is the impact of
particular School uh admission system
change on the school and students well
uh welfare and outcomes and there have
been a growing number and we are on uh
we think that this paper fits into the
second literature as well and when it
comes to the Chilean case obviously we
are not the first one and we are not the
only one there are um many more papers
including these three papers um but the
the focus of the research question is
slightly different depending upon the uh
the authors and ours are different from
theirs mostly because we would like to
understand what makes this universities
to form a centralized matching or expand
the centralized matching so that angle
will be different from other papers
so brief background of Chile
um uh so for fouryear colleges of
University level colleges in Chile we
could classify them into briefly two
group one is called CR and the rest I
call is a non CR the Cris schools can be
considered as Elite schools like IB
League schools in the US they are
established mostly before the
independent period Independence period
initially was started with the eight
schools uh but it split into different
branches and now currently uh into 25
schools the rest of uh rest of fouryear
colleges are currently have uh 35 school
right now in Chile and they are mostly
established in 1980s and why this is the
case be be before this 1980s period The
Establishment uh four-year colleges are
very much limited but the pinet uh allow
for the establish establishment in that
period so their their chunk of uh
schools have been established when they
first started most of them are very
small uh and many of them are under the
guidance of the CR schools so they it's
hard to think it is a usual four-year
colleges but their presence have been
growing over time and in terms of the
share of students they uh they host for
each year uh as of 2011 is it accounts
roughly 50% which is this number I
showed you in terms of the College
admission the two groups of colleges are
very different let me briefly tell you
how it works so in Chile College
freshman quara is set at the beginning
of the cycle by the government uh said
at the beginning and it's not it cannot
be adjusted over the
cycle and before
1967 uh effectively there is no non crit
school but CR School uh runs their own
admission system just like what they
want in the US uh and so on but that
they decided to group a centralized
matching in 200 uh in 1967 and then they
gather the collective application
process and as of 2000 how it works is
that the students who want to apply to
any of the CR school or at least one of
the CR School the student apply online
and they submit their preference ranking
and then once the crw collected all the
information and preference ranking and
then uh test score and the computer uh
runs a Gail shop algorithm for the
student proposal and sped out only one
admission among CR school so that's how
it work uh when comes to non- Cru school
they run their own decentralized
admission system
um uh which is very interesting which I
will show you in a minute um but this
part is something that could be imp
efficiency improving and that's how it
works so what happened in 2012 is that
Cru School initially didn't include this
non- cruch school in terms of the their
centralized matching algorithm but
somehow with a group of the president of
the crud School uh gathered together for
multiple times and this decided uh they
initiated they issued a note that all
nonpr school if they wanted could join
the centralized matching in 2011 and
actually eight of them out of 35 decide
to join and then from 2012 uh 33 schools
uh runs the centralized matching the
coverage in terms of the Freshman quota
that centralized matching accounts for
initially in 2011 was a 50% and
increased to 70% 20 percentage Point
increase which is quite dramatic to my
point so how it works in terms of the
actual College admission is that in
Chile uh all high school senior student
have to take uh an SAT like test that
runs only once a year in December and um
and then the college application starts
in sometime in the mid December so how
it works is that for non for cruit
school as I said before the students log
into website and rank which school and
which school by which major they want
want to apply and they're ranking from 1
to eight so that's how 1 to 10 that's
how it works and then once the
application is done then
sorry the test result will be realized
in early in late December then
application start for the uh online
application for the approach and then it
takes about two to three weeks when the
Gil sh algorithm is speed up the result
and the result comes in then student can
uh enroll for the non-r school how it
works is that once the test were uh
revealed the nonr school start to uh
start to accept application and how they
how they decide which one to accept is
quite sorry I should be one more slide
that has been missing sorry about that
um how they uh make the decision in
terms of the non cruit school is based
on the two fact uh three factors one is
they preset the minimum task score that
which student can get accepted and two
is first come first come first served
even if some student with the perfect
SAT score comes in but if happen to be
that they ex all the qu then this
student cannot get an uh admission from
the non CR and the third one is deposit
so the student have to show up in early
enough so that there is a vacancy for
whatever the college and major they're
interested in and then they have to pass
this minimum test score and pay the
deposit then the student can secure an
admission that's how it works and as you
can see um the application for the non
CR school can uh starts right after the
test score revealed and it's before um
the centralized matching outcome is
revealed the student have to have the
Dual process if they have enough money
to cover the deposit and so on and so
forth so because of this first come
first serve feature student have to go
up early and actually this is the two
photos I uh I borrow from the website
that shows that for this is the
application for one of the non- cruit
school and how it works is that at the 1
a.m when the test score is revealed and
then from the morning or the same day
the morning that the school start to get
an application the students literally
have to line it up and this is 1:00 am
by the time it opens up at 8:30 you will
see all the lines so this is how it
works but if you think about the chil
how it looks it's a long strip of
country and most of this non- Cru School
is located in the capital city called
Santiago so if you if you as a student
happen to live in small City away from
Santiago then literally you have to take
miles take hours of bus to drive to go
to Santiago or you have to fly to
Santiago to line it up for students who
are coming from the relatively quote
unquote poor background will not be easy
to apply to any of these non school so
this is the uh the key feature I
mentioned and in terms of the theory as
I said it's a very simple everyone will
probably see right away that this is an
example model which I'm okay with it but
still it allows me to see what kind of
Statistics I can look for the empirical
part so uh I it just uh model the
situation with the two two College
setting College one and college two and
the quot of the college one and college
two could give an admission is q1 and Q2
which is preset it's less than one which
is measur the size of the student and
college tries to maximize the sum of Tas
score of the Le and this is different
ways but for the empirical part I was
just using as a one so the sum of test
scores of the in Le that's what the
college cares about but because the sum
College actually cares about the number
but also if everything is goes the same
way go if everything else equal the
higher test score will be better off so
just like the simple uh which is a good
summary of the real world but the
students we assume there's a unit
measure and they are different in terms
of the task score and they're
idiosyncratic in terms of the
preferences um so what we assume is that
with the probability P less than one
half a student will prefer College one
to college two and one minus P the
college two preferred College one this
is how I U characterize the preferences
and the uh n is the share of students
who can uh afford the application cost K
and this application cost is needed to
apply for college number two and in this
particular setting College number two is
depicted as a non-r school which you
literally have to fly to line up right
and if a students are able to get a
admission from uh their first choice
either College one or two they will get
a payoff of U of f the second choice
will be U of S not get accepted as at
zero um and if student apply for college
number two will be Ned after the
application cost okay and then again we
we we set up this model try to
understand why colleges form a
centralized matching at the beginning or
why they decide they meaning the CR
School decide to accept a non-is school
in 2012 but not before so we try to
understand why this is the case and this
is the summary of two different system
from the college's point of view so what
would be a a a merit for the college one
or two when it comes to the
decentralized setting in which they run
their own admission um from the setting
uh we assume that students apply for
college number one and two before they
know their true preferences under the
decentralized maging and this may look a
little bit funny because in the real
world they know their test score um but
we use this timing as an assumption
because when you when you think about
the Chilean case they're a dual process
for the centralized mag matching and
decentralized matching um but at the
time student apply for decentralized
match uh non- CR school which runs
decentralized matching the students do
not know what happened in the
centralized matching outcome so this is
a very simple way to depict that
situation um and in in the decentralized
case uh student can apply for two
schools College one and two and
therefore they could the student could
get um at the maximum of two offers and
obviously only one offer can be accepted
so one rejected offer will lead to a
vacancy so that's a decentralized case
but the centralized case we assume the
students real know their preferences
before application because everyone is
under the centralized matching so they
can rank according to their preferences
that's how we assume uh how we depict
the situation and there's no application
cost just like the depicting the
chillian case for the centralized
matching and there is only one offer can
be made and therefore there's No Vacancy
needed so this is a summary of the
situation and what is the relative
benefit of centralized matching compared
to decentralized matching for the
colleges point of view the the best
Merit will be all quotas are filled
because there are more students than the
quota the sum of the quota and therefore
all colleges form a centralized matching
then the by definition there will be no
vacancy because no offer will be
rejected but then because of
decentralized matching um a less
preferred College may lose its top
applicant for the case that they could
perhaps secure on the decentralized case
but it is no longer the case but the
students point of view um this
centralized matching could be useful to
them because eliminating unfield seeds
meaning the uh uh without vacancies the
effective freshman quota is increasing
and therefore more students will be able
to get an admission offer that's a good
thing for everyone on average but then
not every student will be beneficial in
theory because Rich students under the
decentral decentralized matching were
able to uh uh face less competition from
the poor but capable students because
these poor and capable students will not
be able to apply for this uh
decentralized colleges because of the
application cost so this model we show
up the threshold for the cut off that
the test scores and depending upon
whether students are rich versus poor
meaning they can afford
the application versus not we compare
the two cases on the centralized
matching versus non-centralized matching
um but basically what it says is that if
student is uh is wealthy enough to cover
this application cost and their test
score is good enough it doesn't matter
to them except for they secure for the
application cost um but the student
whose test score is very good but not
wealthy enough to apply to their first
prefer most preferred and now better off
because of the centralized matching uh
and there are a group of students who
could be better off because of the uh
reduction of the vacancy that increase
the effective uh College freshman quota
so for the bottom group of students who
will not be able to get an College uh
College admission before under the
decentralized matching but on the
centralized matching now they can get an
offer from uh college so this is the
summary of the model prediction
um so what this Simple Theory tells you
is that perhaps what may be going on in
Chile in terms of understanding why some
colleges decide to form a centralized
matching why they decide to invite some
other colleges to uh join them that may
be uh accounted for by comparability of
colleges for the students who prefer
College some college and the other
colleges are roughly the same share and
also the application cost limits the uh
limits the type uh limits the size of
pools the application size of pools for
the applicants College could tap into in
terms of these aspects if colleges are
comparable then maybe they are better
off to a former College uh former
centralized matching to reduce vacancy
that could be outweigh the possibility
of losing top students for better uh
competing institutions so that's the way
uh we view this system and from the
theory we derive some of the uh
empirical empirically testable cot uh uh
prediction and this is what I will show
you in the data so the data wise we have
a micr level individual application
Level uh uh individual level data from
2010 to
2013 uh we do have some additional
information in terms of the colleges and
college by Major um but unfortunately in
terms of the early period we we don't
have a that detailed level but at least
in terms of the Quant qualitatively we
can we can examine the similar uh
aspects as the letter period but mostly
empirical work is focus on the ear uh
recent periods of 2010 to 2013 so in
terms of the comparability what it means
is that the colleges who join or decide
to join the centralized matching will be
among them will be more comparable and
so what we show you in this table is is
that in 2012 we uh sorry in 2010 to 2011
the before the expansion of the
centralized matching to some of the non-
Cru school we classifi the colleges into
three Group which is the original CR
schools and the non- cruch school who
decide to join the system and the non-
CR school who decide to remain away from
the centralized matching so for the case
of the uh non school who decide to join
the centralized matching these are the
one who should be similar to the CR
school so that's the prediction of the
model and for the raw statistics
relative to the non CR school who decide
to be away from the centralized matching
they look more closer to the Cru school
from the naked eye it's very hard to see
all these different variables so we use
a composite index to predict what kind
of pre uh what type uh what
university joined the centralized
matching in 2012 using the variable that
we C in 2011 predict which one is what
and then we uh plot the predicted
probability for each each school so how
I read this graph is the following so
for the CR School the distribution of
colleges of 25 is located in the upper
part of the predicted uh uh predicted uh
probability and for the non-r school who
join the system is uh distributed with
this red box and the non- college non-
school who decid not to join the system
is uh is distributed with the green one
so what it what this graph tells you is
that these green graphs and blue graphs
are separated in terms of the support
and they are meaning that on average
they are very different whereas the non-
CR school who decide to join are more
likely to overlap with the probability
of accepting this uh centralized magine
and then the the in terms of the
motivation of join the centralized
matching the reduction of the vacancy is
a big deal so we plot the graph is a
2011 and 2012 but the cruch school who
runs the centralized matching in 2011
roughly speaking 50% of their College
admission get rejected and unfilled
whereas in 2012 the number reduced to 8%
so you can say that roughly 50%
reduction in the in terms of the vacancy
which is is consistent with our story
that maybe reduction in vacacy could be
a good reason to why they uh why they uh
want to invite a non CR school to join
their system to uh
uh to Vis to the vacancies so probably I
have three minutes right so I will skip
the regression part basically what it
says is that the in terms of the raw
vacy number in in terms of the sum of
test scores which is modeled in my um
theoretical aspect it goes the same way
and I want to show you this table and
maybe wrap it up and for the uh
empirical Economist like me what this T
this table was very exciting to me what
what it what this table shows is the
following so I rank college by major in
terms of this uh uh in terms of the cut
off score in the historical uh way until
2010 so this is not a function of the
change of this College admission 20 yes
2010 so this is beyond our sample period
and so the the number 100 in ter in
terms of this pre score means that the
the university by Department that has
the highest cut off score so the only
the top top chillion student when in
terms of the PSU score the test score
could go only up to that particular one
and zero means the easiest one to get in
right the higher num the higher number
in terms of The Prestige means that the
student get an admission from more
competitive college byde major option so
what this regression tells you is that
individual
level individual level regression and
controlling for the test score where the
students live in what kind of uh uh
where the students live in the age and
gender and so on that the information we
have um and we regress this uh outcome
the student get an admission from uh in
terms of the what type of high school a
student graduated from so in Chile we
can classify the high school into three
group the public which usually captured
the low social economic uh status
students the voucher students is a
private but it's subsidized by the
government so you can think is a middle
uh uh middle class students can go in
and the private schools are the
expensive one that uh Rich students can
go in so how I read the number is the
conditional on the task score gender and
age and blah blah blah compared to the
private school students the voucher
school students uh end up getting an
admission from and enrolled in in the
lower ranked School a lower lower ranked
school by major but that Gap has been
reduced under the post period when the
expansion of De centralized matching
happened and the reduction of the Gap is
roughly two3 and how is related is that
this uh the gap between private school
versus voucher School conditional on
everything else is uh related to the
3% uh reduction in income for the early
career so this is not
maybe not super big but still to my
point conditional test score everything
just because of the family background is
it could be still lower in terms of
where they can get an admission it's
still something for uh meaningful in
terms of the empirical part and it could
be reduced in the difference reduce in
terms of the College admission system
that lowers the uh application cost so
as
I as I run up with the time so I will
just conclude um so we studied the
system in Chile that you that shows a
very interesting feature of the
voluntary adoption of centralized magic
and we set up a very simple model to
guide us what kind of statistic and
empirical analysis we could do and to me
what I found very interesting and useful
is that one of the the motivation why
the market designers could do uh what
Market designers can do offer in terms
of real word and improving welfare is
helping the policy makers to design a
better system but the real word problem
is that there will be a lot of uh
setbacks and then complaints from some
of the agents who exploit the market
dysfunctions and what this theory in
although it's a simple tells us is that
if the agents are comparable then maybe
it's easier to adopt the better or a
more obvious solution in terms of Market
design so perhaps what the policy makers
point of view could be useful is that
before getting into the intervention it
may be useful to set up a system so that
agents could be more equal or comparable
in terms of their market share and
ability then afterward they may be able
to form uh uh maybe able to adopt a a a
more improved uh matching system so
that's something that could be useful in
the real world all right thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
okay